et pour ce club le grand retour de
Benjamin Morel et Distré alors comment
ça va depuis vendredi mais
pas passer le weekend ensemble je le
précise pour les gens qui nous suivent
Alex nous a rejoint bonjour Alex
rebonjour on parlera avec vous des
manuels Macron surtout les fronts dîner
avec vos leadersky hier soir
multiplication des déplacements en
région et des annonces qui vont avec
interview ce matin dans le Journal
l'opinion ce soir au 20h de TF1 alors
que faut-il voir dans cette
communication tous azimut faut nous le
direz et puis on parlera d'Elizabeth
borne qui va rencontrer les syndicats
demain et après-demain elle veut renouer
le dialogue ils ne veulent pas tourner
la page de la réforme des retraites
alors que peut-il sortir de ces
rencontres vous posera la question
surtout qu'Elisabeth borne est affaibli
on va voir ça avec votre sondage sondage
du Figaro Yves dans quelques instants
d'abord en regardant son de l'actualité
dans nos régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Montpellier retrouver Olivier Biscaye
bonjour Olivier merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur de la rédaction du
Midi Libre et Olivier vous allez nous
parler de la corrida la corrida
va-t-elle faire son grand retour c'est
une question qui dit Olivier oui
absolument il y aura-t-il une corrida le
15 juillet prochain dans les arènes de
Pérols petite ville de 9400 habitants à
quelques kilomètres de Montpellier en la
question agite en effet les pros et
anticorida qui se sont retrouvés devant
le tribunal administratif la semaine
dernière pour les anticorridas la chose
est entendue l'absence de continuité de
tradition locale depuis plus de 20 ans
suffit à déprogrammer je cite la cruelle
corrida du 15 juillet qui selon ses
mêmes associations ne susciteraient
aucun enthousiasme de la part des
habitants réponds faux répondent la
mairie qui annonce avoir déjà vendu à
moitié des 1500 billets prévus justif un
intérêt grandissant alors une bataille
dans un contexte très important ici dans
la région puisque les pros et anticorida
combattent depuis plusieurs mois pour
faire maintenir cette tradition arrêtée
pour les autres le juge rendra son
ordonnance demain mardi 16 mai
à suivre avec le Midi Libre on suivra
bien sûr tout ça avec vous Olivier on va
voir la une du Midi Libre aujourd'hui
autopsie du trafic de drogue et vous
allez nous parler de ce sujet Olivier de
cette lutte contre le trafic de drogue
oui c'est une enquête de l'édition de
Montpellier sur la multiplication des
points de deal qui est exaspèrent autant
les riverains que les autorités la
septième ville de France n'échappe pas à
ce fléau national contre lequel l'État
accentue les moyens on le voit dans dans
ce dossier 400 opérations de lutte
contre les stupéfiants ont été lancés en
2022 dans dans l'Hérault on a beaucoup
de témoignages à la fois de dealer qui
nous disent par exemple et ça devrait
susciter beaucoup de réactions en une
matinée je me faisais 300 euros
justifiant ainsi un système qui s'est
beaucoup développé dans les quartiers de
de Montpellier et puis l'État et la
ville qui se
mobilise contre ce fléau en multipliant
les moyens c'est une enquête réalisée
par nos équipes de la rédaction de 2018
Montpellier et c'est à dire dans le Midi
Libre effectivement cette enquête
autopsie du trafic de drogue c'est à la
une du Midi Libre édition Montpellier
merci beaucoup merci Olivier Biscaye
d'avoir été avec nous un mot sur ce
sujet il va sur cette lutte contre le
trafic de drogue
[Musique]
absolument terrible qui que rencontre
toute l'Europe d'ailleurs parce que il y
a des points d'entrée depuis l'étranger
le port d'Anvers et un véritable
problème il y a eu des enlèvements de
ministres même en Belgique
autour du trafic de drogue et on voit
qu'en France c'est bien rien qu'à la
semaine dernière je crois il y a eu cinq
blessés par armes à feu sur le
territoire français
ici et là ça touche aussi les petites
villes ça touche aussi des zones rurales
c'est un véritable problème et auquel il
va falloir s'attaquer de de très près
c'est pas uniquement dans les grandes
villes Marseille ou Grenoble que ça se
produit
on va parler d'Emmanuel Macron allons-y
allez on commence avec vous Alex puisque
Emmanuel Macron avant de faire le 20h de
TF1 ce soir à bord de ce matin plusieurs
sujets dans une grande interview journal
l'opinion et on commence par la guerre
en Ukraine
de Vladimir Poutine selon président de
la République à la Russie à d'ores et
déjà perdu la guerre géopolitiquement
elle a de facto commencé une
vassalisation à l'égard de la Chine et
elle a perdu l'accès à la Baltique qui
était critique pour elle puisqu'elle a
précipité le choix suédois et finlandais
de rejoindre l'OTAN Emmanuel Macron
rappelle que les occidentaux doivent
continuer à aider militairement
l'Ukraine dans sa contrôle offensive
mais que l'avenir de la sécurité
européenne devra d'un côté sécurisé
l'Ukraine sans rester dans une
confrontation avec la Russie Emmanuel
Macron qui a d'ailleurs et bien dîner
hier avec le président ukrainien volodi
mirzelinski elle est Lisée et il a
annoncé que plusieurs bataillons de
soldats Ukrainiens seraient formés au
pilotage de blindés et de chars français
légers
de cette rencontre cette visite surprise
de vous le dit mirzielinski dont on
apprend d'ailleurs qu'il est en route
pour Londres troisième étape de la
tournée européenne de voladies
merzelinski la France et elle était
importante cette image on a vu Emmanuel
Macron saluer longuement pour le dit
merci dans la cour de l'Elysée oui c'est
évidemment important parce que ça montre
que là-dessus et bien les clés de la
guerre en Ukraine ne se situe pas
caberlin et que donc ce faisant la
France à la fois un rôle avec un
Emmanuel Macron tout de même qui n'avait
pas grand chose à donner en termes
d'ormement de capacité etc et bien il y
avait malgré tout quelques limites
néanmoins et bien l'étape à Paris était
important et ça permet également à à
Zelinski et bien de donner une forme de
change entre les différents dirigeants
occidentaux on a vu que la relation avec
Berlin était pas extrêmement bonne avec
Kiev aujourd'hui à Paris on essaye
également et bien d'étouffer ou en tout
cas de passer de surmonter les éventuels
tensions qui a pu avoir de les semaines
et les mois passés donc aujourd'hui pour
Vladimir pour Vladimir zeninski il
s'agit à la fois de jouer les opinions
publiques entre les dirigeants de jouer
les Etats européens les uns par rapport
aux autres dans l'aide qu'ils peuvent
apporter à l'Ukraine en vue peut-être
demain du notion d'une offensive et puis
évidemment de montrer que derrière
l'Ukraine il y a toute l'Europe
évidemment face à Moscou c'est important
sans doute qu'il fait ça aussi en
préfiguration de cette fameuse contre
offensive qui devrait intervenir
probablement dans les dans les semaines
à venir et il joue sa carte c'est-à-dire
il va jouer essayer de faire de
l'assurance chair vis-à-vis des étapes
pour obtenir le plus possible et Dieu
sait s'il est encore des obstacles à
franchir parce que la France par la voie
de Emmanuel Macron a dit qu'elle ne
donnerait pas pour le moment de matériel
aérien donc ça veut dire qu'il y a
encore des des des
demandes importantes qui va qui va faire
ça va être intéressant son voyage à
Londres parce que Londres
a promis justement de livrer des avions
à vos le direinski on va continuer cette
interview il y a énormément de choses
dans cette interview Alex on va parler
des affaires intérieures il s'est
exprimé assez longuement sur la réforme
des retraites et notamment sur la
proposition de la dabrogation de cette
réforme c'est déposée par le groupe Lyot
et c'est à l'assemblée de 8 juin ah oui
c'est un texte qui peut être ou non voté
par l'Assemblée nationale rien n'est
joué mathématiquement mais le président
de la République se montre très serein
sur le sujet il estime que pour la
majorité présidentielle ça va être
l'occasion et bien de mieux expliquer
cette réforme de retraite c'est selon
lui ce qui a manqué dans les mois
précédents et il demande aussi aux
oppositions de dire dans ce débat et
bien la vérité aux Français sur le
financement de leur mesure et du régime
des retraites car et bien il dit que
certains refusent de travailler plus
longtemps mais je le cite que l'on
m'explique alors comment sans réforme on
finance une proposition de loi à 15
milliards d'euros par le déficit avec
les intérêts à venir
je suis en réduisant d'autres politiques
publiques ou en baissant les pensions en
augmentant les cotisations Emmanuel
Macron posent la question et critique
les propositions de la gauche de faire
payer les gros salaires selon lui ce
sont aussi les classes moyennes qui
paieront avec ce type de propositions et
justement dans cette interview et bien
président de la République rappelle son
objectif de baisser les impôts des
classes moyennes il le dit aujourd'hui
on est de beaucoup les gens qui sont
dans le désarroi qui ont décroché
beaucoup d'aide pour les bas salaires
mais la fiscalité je cite des revenus
des classes moyennes et trop importantes
et s'accélère trop vite elle écrase les
gains de pouvoir d'achat entre 1500 et
2500 euros et mais Macron qui parle de
ceux qui sont trop riches pour être
aidés et pas assez riches pour bien
vivre et par le signe d'immigration il a
été interrogé là-dessus et sur le projet
de loi qui sera présenté en juillet en
conseil des ministres mais oui d'ici là
le gouvernement consulte les
parlementaires pour essayer de
convaincre sur ce texte une majorité de
députés Emmanuel Macron qui explique que
le texte va bien sûr être co-construit
il va évoluer je le cite il y aura une
mise de départ du gouvernement on
regardera comment on peut l'enrichir la
compléter la modifier peut-être
abandonnée des bouts de cette loi afin
de bâtir une majorité mais quelle
majorité sur cette loi migration c'est
la question qui se pose les yeux sont
tournés vers les députés les
républicains qui peuvent apporter les
voies nécessaires au texte mais de leur
côté ils ont aussi leur agenda ils vont
déposer deux propositions de loi sur ce
thème de l'immigration avec des mesures
beaucoup d'attentes de la part des LR et
notamment la modification de la
Constitution pour pouvoir faire un
référendum sur l'immigration Emmanuel
Macron répond sur ce sujet il rappelle
que constitutionnellement actuellement
ce n'est pas possible là en fait il est
assez d'accord avec ricksiotti et les
députés les républicains mais il se dit
prêt à faire des référendums sur tous
les sujets si cela est utile au pays
donc il reste ouvert sur ce sur ce sujet
et on va en parler il y a beaucoup de
sujets dans cette interview Alex le
disait
vous avez pas vu tout dire Alex hein
mais il aborde énormément de thèmes on
sent vraiment la volonté de tourner la
page de la réforme de la réforme des
retraites pour Emmanuel Macron
c'est c'est une ambition même j'ai envie
de dire à ce niveau-là évidemment qu'il
a intérêt puisque c'est quand même un
épisode qui restera
marquant et qui n'a pas été quand même à
l'honneur de de la majorité
présidentielle et qui a qui a été
douloureux quand même pour le président
de la République donc il veut
impérativement mais le problème c'est
que c'est pas lui qui décide et on voit
que il y a une volonté des oppositions
des syndicats probablement des Français
aussi d'une partie des Français de
vouloir continuer à contester cette
cette réforme des retraites je trouve
qu'il est assez optimiste sur le vote du
8 juin il devrait quand même se méfier
parce que on a vu que la motion de
censure il y a quelques semaines était
passé quand même très très près de
elle a été ratée de 8 voix donc il faut
faire attention
non j'en sais rien non j'en sais rien je
pense que normalement ça devrait être la
même le résultat devrait être le même ou
à peu près mais
on sait jamais entre la majorité
relative
qui sont absents
des députés de la majorité qui peut
avoir changer d'avis
il faut faire attention quand même je
pense qu'il a tort de de prendre pour
acquis
la réforme et puis les autres sujets
pour dire la vérité sur tous les autres
sujets c'est le flou le plus absolu le
flou le plus absolu parce que d'abord on
ne sait pas de quoi il retourne
sur le front de la
programmation écologique qu'est-ce qu'il
en est avec ses propos qui viennent
tenir sur le front de l'immigration ne
sait absolument pas ce qu'il y a dans ce
projet
donc il nous parle de baisse d'impôts
d'accord très bien mais ça c'est au
moins une constante chez lui c'est que
il n'a pas augmenté les impôts ce qui
est assez dans un gouvernement français
mais
sur quel sur quelle fiscalité il va il
va œuvrer bon il y a beaucoup de
d'incertitudes avec un couple exécutif
qui est quand même pas non plus d'une
grande harmonie on va parler des choux
dans ce dis Emmanuel Macron il y a une
volonté d'allumer plusieurs contrefeuse
sans pour autant dire trop exactement il
y a trois il y a trois types de
stratégies dans cette interview le
premier type de stratégie c'est en effet
une stratégie de mise à l'agenda
d'autres choses que les retraites et
donc on lance plein de perches et on
espère que il y en ait une ou deux qui
soient saisies qui rentrent dans le
débat public et qu'on en parle l'autre
aspect eh ben c'est dire aux oppositions
chiches en fait la responsabilité du
blocage elle n'incompte pas à moi elle a
un combat vous et là on rejoint en effet
la proposition moi parce que la
proposition de loi Eliote on voit que a
priori on verra ce que ça donne mais il
a pas l'intention non plus de la bloquer
or il y a matière à bloquer et
recevabilité financière obstruction
potentielle de la majorité la a priori
ils sont vouloir aller au vote on verra
ce que font les députés mais néanmoins
il y a une volonté de dire chiche comme
sur le texte immigration le troisième
élément parce qu'il y a ce fameux
article 40 qui empêche les
parlementaires d'alourdir de la charge
financière est-ce que est-ce que là
c'est pas le cas avec ce texte sur les
irrecevabilités financières ça peut
passer dès lors que tout le monde fait
comme si c'est gagé sur le tabac etc si
jamais vous avez un une commission des
finances et derrière une présence de
l'Assemblée nationale qui dit regardez
en fait ça c'est bien gagé et de l'autre
côté un gouvernement qui décide de ne
pas soulever l'article 40 en séance ou
avant en disant il recevabilité
financière si tout le monde est d'accord
pour faire comme si ça passe encore
faut-il que tout le monde soit d'accord
pour faire comme si
Eric Coquerel le sera il est pas sûr que
il y a quoi
normalement le gouvernement et vous avez
un filtre initial par la commission des
finances mais infinie c'est quand même
la présence de l'Assemblée en cas de
désaccord on saisit le Conseil
constitutionnel de désaccords entre
présence de l'assemblée et gouvernement
donc a priori encore une fois si elle
brun pivée a pour objectif de ne pas
bloquer la chose et que le gouvernement
décide de ne pas le faire non plus
qu'Eric Coquerel ne le fait pas non plus
a priori ce sera le cas
exactement
ça peut avancer mais
il y a malgré tout une forme de droit de
veto implicite voyez alors pas absolu
parce qu'on pourrait dire c'est bien
gagé mais c'est quand même très très
discutable au vu des sommes en jeu donc
voilà un petit peu là on a l'impression
que il veut justement aller au combat
dernier aspect parce qu'il est important
on parlait de l'imposition il parle à
son électorat en réalité il a compris
que son électorat était fragilisé qu'il
était aujourd'hui en difficulté avec
cette base électorale qui lui a permis
de tenir quoi qu'il arrive dans
n'importe quelle situation lors des
gilets jaunes la crise covid lors du
dernier quinquennat et que cette base
électorale il faut aujourd'hui lui
parler il faut la considérer il faut la
cajoler et c'est ce qu'il fait
un mot on va parler évidemment de la
réforme des retraites mais sur
l'immigration puisque Alex le disait
c'est un des sujets de cette interview
est-ce que ça va pas être encore plus
compliqué pour lui ce projet de loi
immigration parce que là ça divise au
sein même de sa majorité oui parce que
là on est on est en plein cœur du en
même temps effectivement avec une un
projet de loi qui
ça peut pourrait satisfaire une partie
en partie la gauche et pourrez
satisfaire en partie de la droite sauf
que cette satisfait ni les uns ni les
autres pour la raison précise
précisément que bah il y a boire et à
manger là-dedans donc c'est son problème
et je rejoins ce que disait Benjamin et
son électorat il le connaît et son
électorat d'ailleurs est assez stable sa
base son socle électorale de la palacer
ce socle électoral il est à droite faut
pas se leurrer et il est effectivement
dans la baisse d'impôt mais aussi dans
le maintien de l'ordre républicain et
donc c'est comme c'est pour ça que c'est
assez étonnant pas étonnant mais je
pense il a tort de vouloir insister sur
le volet on va dire social de cette de
cette de ce projet de loi
[Musique]
qui a mon avis l'affaiblit et l'empêche
d'avoir les voix de LR alors maintenant
c'est trop tard à mon avis c'est fini ça
va être encore une source de
d'inquiétude importante pour lui parce
que je pense que ça va être un débat
passionné
à défaut de passionnant d'ailleurs et
qui risque aussi dans lequel il risque
de laisser des plumes oui j'irai même
plus loin que Yves sur les lectorat en
fait la partie de l'électorat de centre
gauche environ un tiers qui lui reste
c'est un électora plutôt valsiste dans
ses valeurs etc quand vous le sondez
notamment sur les questions de sécurité
etc c'est pas du tout un électorat qui
serait mélenchoniste notamment sur ces
sujets là et donc il y a une demande
d'État mais il y a également une demande
qui est relativement libérale et sur le
sujet migration et bien il a des valeurs
mais malgré tout il a une forme gérée de
capitalisme qu'il rapproche de la droite
donc mais c'est pas vraiment
c'est pas vraiment un problème
d'électorat et c'est plus grave pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est un problème de
majorité parlementaire parce que si
jamais il décide de reprendre une
proposition de loi qui pourrait être
accepté par élève vous avez Sacha Willy
et vous avez potentiellement également
le modem et donc vous voyez que
aujourd'hui la priorité pour le chef de
l'État c'est pas tellement le problème
électoral même si évidemment il est
important parce qu'il y a des
européennes mais c'est surtout arrivé à
tenir cette attelage majoritaire non
seulement relatif mais qui tire de lui à
dia alors on revient à la réforme de
retraite puisque Elizabeth borne reçoit
demain et mercredi les syndicats la
première ministre qui veut renouer le
dialogue mais on va voir ce qu'en pense
Sophie Binet la secrétaire général de la
CGT elle était tiers invitée du Grand
Jury LCI RTL le Figaro on écoute
que je vais dire à la première ministre
c'est que il n'y aura pas de retour à la
normale si cette réforme n'est pas
abandonnée la défiance elle est
extrêmement profonde les salariés ne
tourneront pas la page tout simplement
parce que cette réforme elle consiste à
nouveau les deux ans de vie et qu'en
plus le gouvernement veut l'appliquer à
marche forcée et les abattement qui veut
donc relancer le dialogue aborder
d'autres sujets Sophie Binet les autres
syndicats qu'ils ne veulent pas tourner
la page de la réforme des retraites on
est sur un dialogue impossible dialogue
de sourd continue
oui c'est une posture je pense que là
c'est là où toute l'habilité de Madame
borne va être importante il va falloir
qu'elle fasse preuve de beaucoup de
doigtés
parce que c'est vrai qu'elle se retrouve
face à un mur bon les syndicats ne
représentent que ce qu'il représente il
faut pas quand même non plus
sur estimé leur puissance
faut pas oublier que en berger
normalement doit quitter la scène il va
être remplacé alors il va peut-être être
remplacé par quelqu'un qui sera sur la
même ligne que lui c'est à dire au style
assez très fort que Madame Binet
d'accord mais bon c'est pas vous savez
il y a 30 millions d'actifs dans ce pays
et les syndicats malheureusement pour
eux ils représentent une infime partie
de ses actifs et on va voir mais il va
falloir effectivement pour Madame borne
qui est juste de pas mal de d'astuces et
d'audace pour essayer de de de préserver
la paix sociale je dirais d'aut parmi
les regrets d'Elisabeth borne c'est ce
qu'elle redit hier dans le Journal du
dimanche il y a le fait que ça ne se
soit pas mieux passé avec les
partenaires sociaux ça veut dire qu'elle
va devoir faire des concessions
qu'avaient le chercher à tout prix à
Renaud le dialogue pour vous Benjamin
elle a besoin de renouer le dialogue
parce que j'entends et je suis d'accord
avec Yves sur la représentativité des
syndicats sauf que vous avez besoin de
quelqu'un avec qui parler vous avez
besoin d'un interlocuteur souvenez-vous
des gilets jaunes quand vous êtes
personne avec qui parler et bien sortir
d'une crise arrivée à négocier quelque
chose qui pourrait permettre justement
la mise à agenda d'autres projets et de
sortir la séquence des retraites et très
très compliqué donc il faut avoir un
interlocuteur cette interlocuteur les
gouvernements successifs ça date pas
d'Emmanuel Macron les ont souvent mis
quelque peu sous le boisseau voir ne les
ont pas écoutés la réforme des retraites
mais également si vous prenez depuis le
début du quinquennat ou à travailler etc
on fait que les syndicats se sont sentis
extrêmement marginalisés pour ne pas
dire fouet et donc aujourd'hui renommer
un contrat de conscience de confiance
avec ses interlocuteurs en vue de
changer de séquence va être extrêmement
extrêmement difficile
est-ce qu'il y a un jeu dupe la réponse
est oui parce que tout le monde a
compris que après en tout cas le 8 juin
il allait falloir parler d'autre chose
mais aujourd'hui à la fois parce que les
syndicats sont manque de
représentativité justement doivent
parler à l'opinion et à leur base et que
en même temps et ben ils ont bien
compris que c'était un outil pour être
sur le devant de la scène ça va être
très très compliqué de les faire changer
d'avis d'autant Elisabeth borne qui va
fêter demain c'est un an à Matignon est
assez affaibli il y a un sondage ce
matin dans Le Figaro Yves qui dit que
62% des Français ne veulent plus
d'Elisabeth borne à Matignon oui alors
bon c'est un sondage qui est très
négatif c'est vrai pourquoi parce que
probablement que il avait de borne doit
payer son côté un peu austère très sobre
très technicienne avec assez peu
finalement d'empathie dans la dans la
façon d'être et de faire et puis
probablement aussi c'est un c'est une
conséquence de la cette réforme des
retraites qui auprès de beaucoup de
Français
et mal passé et donc elle en paie les
pots cassée elle est tenue pour
responsable peut-être du manque de
dialogue et du manque d'explication
qu'on reproche à l'exécutif qui est tout
à fait excessif d'ailleurs à mon avis ce
reproche enfin bon c'est elle paye tout
ça et
pour dire la vérité c'est assez injuste
parce que le Président de la République
a laissé se débrouiller quand même pas
mal de temps seul d'ailleurs il regrette
lui d'A pas avoir regrette un peu
stériori de pas avoir été suffisamment
présent sur ce dossier voilà
vous savez c'est un fusible un premier
ministre donc je pense que s'il y avait
eu un autre Premier ministre ça serait
probablement pas passé beaucoup mieux
oui c'est un fusil mais c'est un fusible
qui ne marche pas quand vous regardez
l'école de popularité des présidents de
la République hors cohabitation quand
vous faites sauter le fusible les codes
de popularité du chef de l'État ne
remonte jamais tout à fait donc vous
avez un nouveau Premier ministre il peut
être populaire qu'un jour mais en Greg
général ça ne dure pas donc la question
c'est certes Elizabeth borne n'est pas
très populaire mais je rejoins Yves
certes mais un autre serait-il plus
populaire qu'elle aujourd'hui et surtout
en quoi changer la personnalité qui
détient Matignon et ben changerait
fondamentalement la donne en quoi ça
permettrait d'avoir une majorité
parlementaire encore une fois clé de la
suite du quinquennat de renouer avec
l'électorat de la République en marche
qui aujourd'hui très divisé c'est loin
d'être évident donc aujourd'hui
Elisabeth borne n'est peut-être pas tout
à fait la première ministre rêvée pour
Emmanuel Macron mais faute de grive on
mange des merles
pourquoi parler de la prochaine échéance
électorale ce sont les Européennes et de
ce sondage hier dans le Journal du
Dimanche sur cette élection c'est le
rassemblement national qui arriverait en
tête si l'élection avait lieu suivi de
la majorité présidentielle si la gauche
part divisée si la gauche réussit à
faire une liste unique et bien le
rassemblement national et la nuque
seraient à égalité qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce sondage
alors je pense que le
l'intérêt principal de ces sondages il a
eu plusieurs c'est savoir si la gauche
doit partir unie ou la gauche doit
partir
chaque partie de la gauche dans son
couloir si j'ai bien compris la gauche
qui part en ordre dispersé finalement le
faire meilleur score et comme c'est un
comment un scrutin à un tour
de liste elle a peut-être elle a intérêt
à rester je dirais à ce que chaque
partie partent avec ses propres forces
et d'ailleurs ça permettrait
probablement de montrer si on en croit
le le sondage au Parti socialiste et aux
écologistes de dire bah on fait jeu égal
avec la France insoumise et que je
dirais que la
primauté de la France soumise et la main
mise sur la gauche de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon serait remise la
question d'une certaine façon donc il
est là l'intérêt c'est le principal
intérêt de ce sont de ce sondage c'est
de nous montrer que la gauche a
peut-être pas intérêt à partir unie sur
ce que tu as et avant de vous faire
réagir Benjamin on va écouter marine
tondeelier la secrétaire nationale
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts qui défend à
une liste autonome de son parti qui dit
que c'est une élection à la
proportionnelle et qui est assez
fataliste sur la victoire du
rassemblement national et ce n'est pas
une liste commune de la gauche qui
changera les choses on l'écoute elle
était invitée de France 3 hier midi en
2027 on est réussi d'ici là à tracer un
chemin d'espoir et de victoire parce que
je pense que énormément de français des
Français ne se résignent pas à devoir
choisir au deuxième tour entre
l'héritier que ce sera choisi de
macronisme et Marine Le Pen être
ensemble européenne ne résout rien à ce
problème on sera pas devant c'est pas
vrai c'est pas par contre il faut aller
chercher des électeurs déçus et ça on va
pas chercher les mêmes Fabien Roussel
moi manuel Bompard et le Parti
socialiste comme ça c'est plus efficace
des listes divisées de la nuque comme le
dit marine tondelei de toute façon le RN
arrivera en tête même si la gauche est
unie alors ça dépend ce que vous voulez
faire en réalité c'est à dire que alors
est-ce qu'il y a un effet vote utile aux
européennes théoriquement c'est pas
cohérent parce que voter utile comme la
bien dit c'est un scrutin
proportionnelle nationale avec un seul
tour donc il y a pas de vote utile en
revanche on l'a vu aux dernières
européennes le vote utile en fait ça
compte parce que vous avez ce jeu de
petits chevaux entre les grandes disques
qui pourraient arriver en tête
souvenez-vous c'est l'effet Bellamy avec
un électorat qui est totalement divisé
entre le RN et la République en marche
et qui fait que LR est complètement
écartelée donc malgré tout si la gauche
part en ordre dispersé et un risque de
démobilisation d'électorat mais l'union
des disques risque de faire que les
têtes de liste ne plaisant pas beaucoup
vous avez des soucieux démocrates qui
voudront pas voter pour une liste avec
que des LFI etc il peut y avoir
également une déperdition donc ça c'est
le premier risque il faut bien
comprendre que quand vous regardez le
sondage ce qui est assez marquant et ce
qui confirme un peu les dernières
législatives c'est que vous avez un
fonctionnement par bloc il y a trois
grands blocs grosso modo bloc centriste
bloc de gauche nup et bloc et il y a peu
de l'intercommunalité entre ces blocs ce
qui change et ben c'est le taux de
participation et à une élection
européenne vous avez environ au moins
50% d'abstention et ben celui qui peut
l'emporter et celui qui mobilise le
mieux son électorat qu'est-ce qui est le
plus mobilisateur la gauche humide
demandée par une grande partie des
électeurs selon les sondages ou bien des
listes qui correspondent beaucoup plus à
l'idée que vous faites de la politique
selon la nuance de gauche dans laquelle
vous êtes l'autre élément qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est que une campagne des
européennes avec des vers qui tuent qui
tirent sur des LIFI des Lafi qui tirent
sur des communistes et des communistes
qui tirent sur des socialistes c'est
très très dur à tenir pour la nuque or
il faut tenir par la suite encore et ça
ça va être un élément qui va être un
élément fondamental parce que
aujourd'hui s'il a une explose là
Emmanuel Macron peut dissoudre et en
effet il peut y avoir une majorité
absolue donc arrivé à faire tenir cette
attelage Nupe dès lors que vous tirez à
balle réel pendant une campagne c'est
compliqué or dans une campagne quand
vous êtes le Parti communiste où elle
est fi vous pouvez tirer sur le RN mais
c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire rapporter
des électeurs vous ne des électeurs que
on les obtenant à des parties proches
des parties qui sont proches de vous
donc ce sont eux pour vrais adversaires
arrivé pour la nuit à survivre à ces
élections risque d'être très compliqué
et ça en effet ça plaiderait plus pour
nous
européenne et LFI risque encore plus
gros oui parce que c'est un peu une
heure de vérité on sait très bien qu'il
ne pense pas tous la même chose sur
cette sur ce sujet sur le sujet européen
la division est énorme
et d'ailleurs ils l'ont mis ils l'ont
mise de côté jusqu'à présent mais c'est
sûr que là là il y a des il y a des
motifs de division très très forts très
violents et
je suis curieux de voir comment ça peut
ça peut se résoudre
la majorité présidentielle qui reste
quand même assez haute dans ce sondage
ça veut dire que les européennes ne
seront pas en vote sanction contre
Emmanuel Macron bah c'est un peu ce
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure Emmanuel
Macron a une base électorale et pour
l'instant cette base électorale n'est
pas vraiment concurrencée dessus il y a
pas de liste alternative centrices qui
permettrait de façon évidente à cette
électorat de se replier sur une offre
alternative donc aujourd'hui on est fait
on voit que cette base électorale sont
tristes demeure mais demeure
essentiellement sous l'eau patronage
d'Emmanuel Macron il est pas certain que
si demain vous envoyez quelqu'un d'autre
ou que Emmanuel Macron ne soit pas en
première ligne et bien cette base
électorale reste soudée donc ça peut
tenir pour les européennes pas sur cette
chaîne en 2027
il sera nécessairement très présent
parce que c'est pas lui qui va
évidemment tirer la liste mais c'est lui
qui va la porter peut-être en plus il a
un discours alors là pour le coup qui
est sans ambiguïté c'est probablement un
des sujets sur lequel il a le moins
d'ambiguïté il est très pro européen il
en parle plutôt assez bien
et
là-dessus on avait vu qu'après l'épisode
des gilets jaunes où on donnait pas cher
de sa peau aux élections européennes
mais il avait réussi à maintenir le
quand même un score assez assez bon
juste derrière le rassemblement national
et donc on va voir si réédite l'exploit
d'une certaine façon alors que la
popularité est grande quand même oui il
faut bien comprendre qu'en plus s'il a
un avantage pour ces élections parce que
c'est des élections dans lequel dans
lesquelles l'abstention est assez
importante du coup qui va voter qui est
sur représenté si je suis très
caricatural et CSP+ et les retraités qui
est-ce qui vote pour Emmanuel Macron a
majoritairement en tout cas d'un point
de vue différentiel les CSP+ et les
retraités donc c'est un scrutin réveil
pour deux parties la République en
marche et les Verts d'où le fait que les
deux et ben attendent cette ce moment-là
avec plus ou moins d'impatience tous les
5 ans à faire à suivre on va regarder ce
qu'elle a une de nos quotidien régionaux
avec vous Alex
[Musique]
et Alex on commence avec la Une de
Sud-Ouest les pompiers se préparent au
feu de forêt cet été
à l'affût pour éviter les incendies
dramatiques de l'été dernier dans le
département on le rappelle près de 29000
hectares de forêt avait brûlé au final
et cette année les pompiers ont intégré
une nouveauté dans leur stratégie ils
vont faire des manœuvres d'exercices
désormais à la lisière des forêts et
plus en caserne comme c'était le cas
auparavant l'objectif c'est d'être
encore plus réactif en cas de départ de
feu mais aussi de montrer que les
pompiers sont sur le terrain en forêt de
montrer l'uniforme comme on dit pour
dissuader certains esprits mal
intentionnés une vingtaine de tours de
Gai sont également disposés partout dans
le massif forestier et cette année elles
seront renforcées d'un système de vidéo
surveillance pour avoir un oeil encore
plus attentif sur l'état de la forêt cet
été on se prépare au feu de forêt en
Gironde et dans les Pyrénées-Orientales
c'est la sécheresse actuelle qui
préoccupe les élus mais oui c'est-à-dire
aujourd'hui dans l'Indépendant catalan
une vingtaine de communes du département
touché par la sécheresse actuellement et
bien Redoute manque d'eau potable cet
été plusieurs élus se sont donc lancés
dans une course contre-la-montre pour
éviter cette pénurie il demande par
exemple des autorisations pour réaliser
de nouveaux forages dans des nappes
phréatiques profondes c'est le cas dans
la commune de Lille sur terre ou le
Maire demande se demande aussi s'il ne
va pas fermer par exemple la piscine
municipale cet été la commune thé
commune la communauté de communes
voisines agli fenouyed a déjà vécu il y
a plusieurs années des pénuries d'eau
potable et en prévision et bien elle a
commandé deux palettes de bouteilles
d'eau ça fait trois millilitres 3 ml de
bouteille d'eau et ça permet de tenir
quelques jours en cas de rupture brutale
mais voilà les élus sont plutôt inquiets
sur l'été à venir elle a une de Nice
Matin on parle d'un autre défi de l'été
recruté dans le secteur de l'hôtellerie
restauration oui avec un chiffre
impressionnant à la Une de Nice Matin
200000 postes sont à pourvoir dans ce
secteur actuellement en France alors
c'est moins que l'an dernier où il y
avait 320 000 postes manquants la
situation reste très tendue dans
l'hôtellerie restauration des postes non
pourvu qui s'expliquent par les
difficultés du secteur des métiers qui
ne sont pas attractifs un manque de
logement dans les grandes villes et puis
aussi un manque de nombreux apprentis
pour faire fonctionner l'établissement
c'est lundi on finit par du foot on
finit par du foot surtout qu'il reste
seulement quelques jours dans ce
championnat de Ligue 1 donc là le
suspense est à son compte notamment dans
le haut du tableau l'Olympique de
Marseille et toujours dans la course à
la deuxième place après sa victoire hier
trois ans contre Angers c'était la Une
de La Provence en bas du classement
Toulouse a assuré son maintien en Ligue
1 après un match nul 00 contre Nantes
c'est à la Une de La Dépêche du Midi et
puis c'est presque fait aussi le
maintien pour Brest à la une du
Télégramme après une victoire contre
Auxerre et en revanche pour trois set
officiellement fini trois va descendre
officiellement en Ligue 2 après sa
défaite 4 à 0 contre Rennes c'est à la
Une de l'Est éclair bon match très beau
match
merci beaucoup Alex merci Benjamin Morel
Yves la Une du Figaro un an après le
couple borne Macron sous tension
que je vous recommande avec ou sans
borne
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi si vous
voulez voir au revoir cette émission
c'est sur notre nouvelle plateforme
public sénat.fr prochain rendez-vous à
18h sans public Thomas Hugues et puis il
va 19h30 audition publique
on vous retrouve tout à l'heure arrive
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain très bonne journée
[Musique]